Speaker 1: One of the major revelations of
the Trump tax returns has nothing to do with
Donald Trump.
It actually has to do with the IRS.
And there's a really good article in The Daily
Beast by Sean Wu called We Haven't Seen Trump's
Taxes Yet, but it's clear the IRS failed America.
The IRS is required to conduct audits of the
president and vice president while they're
in office.
But Trump apparently got a pass.
We'll link to the article in the description
for the YouTube video that we're going to
put up.
But let's talk about the big picture here.
The IRS didn't even audit the president, who's
supposed to be audited as a matter of automatic
principle.
It's supposed to be mandatory audit of the
president.
And as you zoom out, you find yet another
one of these projection hypocrisy logic pretzels
that the right often gets itself into.
They complain about the IRS.
The IRS is too big and the IRS is cracking
down too much on the wealthy.
And the IRS is politically biased in going
after the conservatives, even though we know
that that's actually that that was an Obama
era pseudo scandal, which has been completely
debunked.
And they say we're for law and order.
And yet what we see is they never want to
fully fund the IRS and they seem perfectly
happy or at least indifferent to the fact
that the IRS isn't even really doing the minimum.
It's almost like they don't really want rich
people and in particular rich conservatives
to have to follow the rules pre-dating this
specific incident.
Think back.
The IRS has a history of discrimination and
unequal enforcement, especially against marginalized
communities and small business owners.
We could also look at the ongoing issues with
the IRS is outdated and error prone systems,
which for average taxpayers just make it really
difficult to get your taxes done.
People often end up going to paid services,
even though there are often free services
available depending on your income.
The confusion and the frustration that the
IRS continues to put taxpayers through average
taxpayers, combined with the tax software
lobby, which is very strong, create a situation
where for many of the average taxpayers with
average incomes, it's both more expensive
and more complicated and frustrating and convoluted
to file your taxes than it has to be.
While meanwhile, the very rich and the privileged
take advantage of all sorts of different mechanisms
to often end up paying a dramatically lower
effective tax rate than people with significantly
lower incomes.
That's a failure of the IRS and of the elected
officials that dictate tax policy and manage
the IRS.
And then when you think about what is this
really done?
The IRS has played a major role in enabling
corruption and abuses of power by the wealthy
and powerful by turning a blind eye to what
is and again, with tax avoidance and evasion
of I believe avoidance is legal, whereas evasion
is not.
There's a gray area there in terms of the
spirit of of a lot of these laws, if not the
letter, by turning a blind a blind eye to
it and failing to even adequately audit and
investigate high income people in corporations.
They are allowing the wealthy to buy their
way out of paying their fair share above and
beyond what the tax code is even trying to
achieve.
So this is the type of stuff that erodes trust
and faith in government.
And meanwhile, they want to tell you, oh,
Biden wants to double the size of the IRS
and arm everyone when the truth is that there's
55,000 IRS people expected to retire over
the next ten years.
55,000 of the new hires are just to replace
people that are retiring.
That just gets us to where we are now in terms
of their arming the IRS.
The IRS has a small law enforcement division.
So does Amtrak.
So does the MTA in New York City.
It's not really a big deal.
It's not actually an authoritarian police
state crack down.
They want to focus on that when the truth
is the IRS is dramatically undersized and
underpowered.
And that's really what we're learning from
the Trump tax return story